people do astonishingly little and
that's okay cuz humans are meant to
conserve energy we're predisposed to
laziness there's a time for leverage but
sometimes it's just violence it's just
Brute Force it's forcing the outcome
most people can't comprehend that
someone is doing 50 times more work than
them if you suck at Cold calls do more
cold calls not twice as many do 20 times
more and you'll get better 20 times
faster than you would and I actually
think it's even faster than that cuz if
you do 20 times the calls one guy does 3
hours of calls a week and I do 60 hours
of calls a week so 20 20 times the
output it would takeen 20 weeks to get
to that same number of reps but because
my Fe back Loops are shorter I also get
better faster I do more work in a
shorter period and then my skill also
improves faster then you look like an
outlier on the map and everyone's like
what did this guy do it's like he
literally did 20 times more work